>> Laura: HOUSE SPEAKER PAUL
RYAN'S ANNOUNCEMENT IS NOT GOING
TO SEEK REELECTION HAS IGNITED A
CONTEST TO REPLACE HIM BETWEEN
THE ESTABLISHED WING OF THE
G.O.P. AND THE MORE CONSERVATIVE
POPULIST WING.
IN LAST NIGHTS ANGLE, I SAID THE
SECRET DEPARTURE IS A CLEAR SIGN
TRUMP'S VISION, NOT RYAN'S, IS
THE FUTURE OF THE PARTY.
THAT THE ESTABLISHMENT MAY
FINALLY BE CEDING THE PARTY TO
THE MAN WHO TOOK IT FROM THEM IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
HOWEVER, RYAN CLAIMED TODAY THAT
THE MORE POPULIST STEVE SCALISE
HAS CONCEDED THE SPEAKERSHIP TO
THE ESTABLISHMENT FAVORITE,
KEVIN McCARTHY.
THAT'S NOT EXACTLY WHAT STEVE
SCALISE SAID THIS MORNING.
>> YOU ARE IN THE ROOM NEXT TO
YOUR COLLEAGUE KEVIN McCARTHY.
YOU ARE SEEN AS THE FRONT
RUNNERS FOR THIS ROLE.
WOULD YOU RUN UP AGAINST HIM?
>> NO, AND I'VE SAID THAT BEFORE
>> NO, AND I'VE SAID THAT BEFOR
BEFORE.
I'VE NEVER RUN AGAINST KEVIN AND
I WOULDN'T.
>> Laura: WHY NOT?
IS KEVIN McCARTHY UNTOUCHABLE?
COME ON, STEVE.
THAT LEAVES A LOT OF WIGGLE
ROOM.
LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH SOMEONE
WHO ONE CHAIRED THE G.O.P. PARTY
IN RYAN'S HOME STATE OF
WISCONSIN.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF REINCE PRIEBUS JOINS US
FOR AN INCLUSIVE INTERVIEW ON
"THE ANGLE."
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO BE
IN STUDIO.
I AM SO BUMMED.
WHERE ARE YOU?
WHY AREN'T YOU HERE QUESTION!
I HAVE AN EARLY FLIGHT IN THE
MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
I APPRECIATE YOU LETTING ME DO
IT REMOTE.
>> Laura: NO PROBLEM.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO GET INTO THE
COMEY NONSENSE AND A SECOND, THE
COMEY BOOK.
NOW WE ARE JUST HOWLING BECAUSE
IT'S LIKE, HIS TIES TO LONG.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A SECOND.
TELL ME ABOUT THE RYAN
DEPARTURE.
SOME CONVERSATION TODAY I HEARD
THAT THERE'S A PUSH TO HAVE RYAN
LEAVE SOONER.
DON'T SPEND THE NEXT SIX MONTHS
WITH THIS INTRIGUE ABOUT WHO'S
GOING TO REPLACE HIM.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO LEAVE, WHY
NOT LEAVE NOW?
INSTEAD OF THE END OF THE YEAR?
IS THERE ANY WISDOM TO THAT?
TO GO I DON'T THINK SO, LAURA.
I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT MARK
MEADOWS SAID TODAY, HE DIDN'T
THINK SO EITHER.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
WHEN PEOPLE LIKE MARK WALKER
FROM THE STUDY GROUP AND MARK
MEADOWS FROM THE FREEDOM CAUCUS
AND PEOPLE IN THE MIDDLE ARE NOT
SAYING THAT, I THINK IT TELLS
YOU WHAT YOU NEED TO KNOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
AND I DO THINK, I KNOW IT'S HARD
TO BELIEVE IN POLITICS.
I THINK RYAN LEAVING AND ALL OF
THE OTHER INTRIGUE IS MORE
COINCIDENTAL WITH HIS TIMING,
HOW LONG HE WANTS TO SERVE.
IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT, HE'S
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS ACTUALLY
FOR YEARS, OF HANGING IT UP AND
SPENDING MORE TIME AT HOME.
IT WAS A TOUGH CALL.
>> Laura: SO IT'S NOT, SO IT'S
NOT -- SORRY TO INTERRUPT.
REINCE, IT'S NOT BECAUSE HE'S
FRUSTRATED THEY ARE GOING TO GO
IN THE MINORITY.
THEY ARE GOING TO PUSH THE
REMOVE TRUMP FROM OFFICE, IT'S
GOING TO BE A NIGHTMARE FOR THE
NEXT YEAR AND A HALF.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT PLAYED INTO
IT AT ALL?
>> WELL, NO, I DON'T.
I THINK IF YOU RUN AND YOU WIN
AND YOU HAVE, YOU ONLY HAVE A
TWO VOTE MAJORITY, HE CAN'T
LEAVE THEN EITHER BECAUSE THEN
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
YOU ARE GOING TO BE THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE WITH A TWO VOTE
MAJORITY AND PUT A CONGRESSIONAL
SEAT IN PLAY?
YOU REALLY HAD NO OTHER OPTION.
HE COULD HAVE RUN AGAIN, GOTTEN
IN THE MINORITY, AND THEN RESIGN
BUT IT WOULDN'T OF BEEN HONEST
THE PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE.
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER WAY.
WHEN YOU GO TO PANCAKE
BREAKFASTS, LAURA, AND I KNOW
YOU KNOW POLITICS AND YOU DO
THESE THINGS TOO.
WHEN YOU GO TO PANCAKE
BREAKFASTS FOR 20 YEARS AND
THESE LITTLE TOWNS YOU
REPRESENT, IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO ASK PEOPLE TO PUT UP FOUR BY
8-YARD SIGNS ALL OVER THE
DISTRICT KNOWING THAT COME
JANUARY, YOU'RE ONLY GOING
TO SAY I'M OUT OF HERE, AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO GO HOME AND
LIVE
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT YOU JUST LE
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT YOU JUST LD
TO, THERE'S NO WAY AROUND IT.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY,
PRIVATELY TALKING TO PAUL, AND I
KNOW HIM WELL.
HE WAS HAVING A LOT OF FUN AND
GETTING A LOT OF THE WORK DONE,
AND HE HAD A LOT OF FUN AND HAD
A LOT OF ENJOYMENT OUT OF
WORKING WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Laura: PEOPLE DON'T THINK
THAT.
>> IT'S NOT TRUE.
CERTAINLY THEY HAVE THEIR TIMES
IN THE BEGINNING THAT WERE COME
AND GO AND HIT OR MISS.
ONCE THEY GOT TO KNOW EACH OTHER
AND ONCE THEY STARTED SPENDING
TIME TOGETHER, HE ACTUALLY WAS
HAVING A GOOD TIME.
>> Laura: THAT'S NICE.
THAT'S NICE.
GLAD TO HEAR IT.
VERY HALLMARK.
THEY DO HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS,
TRADE, IMMIGRATION, WAY
DIFFERENT VIEWS.
IS IT A TRUMP PARTY NOW, REINCE?
>> WAIT A SECOND.
I DON'T THINK, ON IMMIGRATION, I
DON'T THINK THEY HAD A DIFFERENT
VIEW.
THE PRESIDENT AND PAUL RYAN WERE
PRETTY MUCH LOCKS UP.
ON DACA, THE PRESIDENT WENT FROM
800,000 TO 1.6.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THE PRESIDENT
DID.
>> Laura: THE ORIGINAL.
>> YOU HAVE COME A LONG WAY TOO,
LAURA.
>> Laura: TRUMP ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL, PAUL RYAN WAS
UNCOMFORTABLE EVERY MINUTE OF
THE DAY.
EVEN AFTER TRUMP WINS THE
NOMINATION COME HE DIDN'T GIVE A
FULL THROATED ENDORSEMENT.
IT WAS LIKE PULLING TEETH.
IT'S CRYING OVER SPILLED MILK.
I'M GOING TO ASK ABOUT THE COMEY
BOOK.
>> I'M NOT DENYING THAT.
I'M SAYING IS THEY GOT TO KNOW
EACH OTHER, THEY WORKED WELL
TOGETHER.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK KEVIN
McCARTHY GETS IT?
>> I KNOW THE PRESIDENT LIKES
HIM WHOLE LOT BUT HE ALSO REALLY
RESPECTS STEVE.
SO I THINK IT'S A TOUGH CALL FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT'S A TOUGH CHOICE FOR
THE PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE.
BUT LOOK, I THINK THERE'S PLENTY
OF TIME FOR THIS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT THE
$40 MILLION HAS ALREADY BEEN PUT
IN THE BANK SO EVERYTHING NOW
THAT THE PARTIES BRINGING IN IS
ICING ON THE CAKE.
THE RNC IS ALSO TOP OF IT,
CRUSHING THE DNC.
MONEY IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
ISSUE.
>> Laura: CHANCES WE KEEP THE
HOUSE?
>> 4.5?
I THINK IT'S RIGHT AROUND A COIN
FLIP.
I THINK THE WIND IS AT THE
REPUBLICANS' FACE.
SOME OF THE RECENT ELECTIONS ARE
PRETTY SCARY.
I THINK THE WISCONSIN OUTCOME IS
A WAKE-UP CALL FOR THE PARTY.
THEY HAVE TO TRIPLE DOWN ON
VOTER IDENTIFICATION TURNOUT AND
I THINK IT'S TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'VE GOT THE RIGHT
CANDIDATES ON THE BALLOT.
IF IT'S POSSIBLE TO GET RID OF
SOME BAD CANDIDATES, WE SHOULD.
WE SHOULD PUT BETTER CANDIDATES
IN THEIR PLACE.
THAT'S WHERE IT'S GOING TO COME
DOWN TO.
>> Laura: THIS FEED BOOK, WE
ARE ALMOST OUT OF TIME.
GIVE ME YOUR THUMBNAIL READ.
I KNOW YOU HAD A FEW
INTERACTIONS WITH COMEY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE?
>> I DID.
LISTEN, I'VE HEARD ALL THE
CONVERSATION YOU HAD.
IT WAS GREAT IN THE SEGMENT
BEFORE AND I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
A LOT THAT WAS SAID.
ONE THING I WOULD SAY THAT I
HAVEN'T HEARD IS HOW GENERALLY
IMPROPER IT IS FOR THE HIGHEST
APPOINTED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN THE COUNTRY TO TURN
AROUND A HALF YEAR LATER AND
WRITE A KISS AND TELL ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
EVERYONE HAS THEIR GRIPES.
AND I'M SURE I COULD TELL YOU
PRIVATELY A FEW GRAPES OF MY
OWN.
IT'S JUST NOT A PROPER THING TO
DO TODAY, ESPECIALLY GIVEN HE
WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
>> Laura: DID YOU LIKE HIM?
DID YOU LIKE HIM WHEN YOU DEALT
WITH HIM?
>> I ACTUALLY DIDN'T DEAL WITH
HIM ALL THAT MUCH, LAURA.
SORT OF A DUBIOUS TYPE OF THING
WHERE IT'S JUST SOMEONE WHO
COMES IN AND OUT VERY CAREFULLY,
VERY QUIETLY.
SOME INTERACTIONS IN THE
SITUATION ROOM.
SOME INITIAL INTERACTIONS EARLY
IN TRUMP TOWER.
OTHER THAN THAT, THERE WASN'T A
WHOLE LOT BETTER.
A LOT MORE IS ANALYZED AND MADE
UP OF IT THAN IT ACTUALLY WAS.